when i listen to podcasts i'm into like
the lore like the hard lore like i just
love like dan carl and i'm like give me
the facts just like
like the facts into my bloodstream but
you also don't know
like you're a fascinating mind to
explore so you don't realize as you're
talking about stuff the stuff you've
taken for granted
is actually unique and fascinating the
way you think
not always what like the way you reason
through things is the fascinating thing
okay to listen to listen to because
people kind of see oh there's other
humans that think differently that
explore thoughts differently
that's the cool that's that's also cool
so yeah dan carlin retelling of history
by the way his retelling of history
is very
i think what's exciting is not the
history is
his way of thinking about history no i
think dan carlin is one of the people
like when dan carl was one of the people
that really started getting me excited
about like revolutionizing education
because like dan carlin instills
instilled
i already like really like liked history
but he instilled like an obsessive love
of history in me to the point where like
now i'm [ __ ] reading like
like going to bed
reading like part four of the rise and
fall of the third reich or whatever like
i got like dense ass history but like
like he like opened that door that like
made me want to be a scholar of that
topic like it's like i feel like he's
such a good teacher he just like
you know and and it sort of made me feel
like
one of the things we could do with
education is like
find like the world's great the teachers
that like
create passion for the topic because
it
auto didacticism i don't know how to say
that properly but like self teaching is
like much faster than being lectured to
like it's much more efficient to sort of
like be able to teach yourself and then
ask a teacher questions when you don't
know what's up but like you know
that's why it's like in university and
stuff like you can learn so much more
material so much faster because you're
doing a lot of the learning on your own
and you're going to the teachers for
when you get stuck but um like these
teachers that can inspire passion for a
topic i think that is one of the most
invaluable skills in our whole species
like because if you can do that then you
it's like ai like ai
is gonna
teach itself so much more efficiently
than we can teach it we just need to get
it to the point where it can teach
itself
and then it finds the motivation to do
so right yeah so like you inspire it to
do so yeah and it could it could change
itself
you